What I collect is mainly Iron Man Hot Toys
and till date I have 105 figures.
Hi I'm Terence Tee
I'm 37 years old this year and
currently in the real estate industry
I will display them in a certain order
I have arranged The Iron Legion,
which consists of Mk I to now Mk 47.
I will also customise certain figures as per what I want that was seen in the movie
Actually, my figures they are not as
precious as some collectors because I
will dismantle them, I will display them,
I will play with it.
I will try to display individual parts of the Iron Man figures,
like helmets, the arc reactors, gauntlets and figures.
so every piece looks very unique.
Of course there are some collectors that might think I went overboard
by destroying a very expensive figure by dismantling it.
But for me I think that
is it's the passion of how much I want
my display to be
As a very impatient collector, I do
customise figures not available in the market.
For customization, I will rely on
this Iron Man manual.
I have to study what are the colours,
what are individual parts consists of
then I gotta go and source for the parts
and then proceed with the customization.
A single mark can consist of up to four figures.
For example, for this, it is the mk 13.
The torso
consists of maybe mk 40 but the
shoulder pads comes from a mark 7
of course I have to learn how to
airspray it, I got to learn how to attach
things, I've got to putty, and sand it
off to achieve that custom that I'm
trying to build.
It really does take time and effort. The
hardest part is actually the masking.
Mask it, spray it, unmask it, and then do
the same process for the rest of the
part. Attach them back together and make sure
everything looks good
according to what was in the manual.
Of course during this period I did break
certain pieces. Things that I broke which
I couldn't fix I will try to put them
into this diorama which I did. This
diorama actually consists of all the
figures that I have, which I display them
as all those has already perished like
Thanos' Gauntlet holding on to Spider-Man's mask
I have figures of broken shield from Captain
America, Iron Man armor that was being
destroyed. Most of the Avengers figures that I have all the spare parts I will
all put inside the diorama.
The one that I find most unique about my display
are the Holograms. because it is not
available on market. Thanks to some
customizers. They have to cast every individual part
and they have to attach them together.
It even comes with a light up feature.
The biggest figure that I have is
the Hot Toys
Iron Man Mark 44, which is the Hulkbuster.
It is about 12 kg and it's very detailed,
although it is not very pose-able
This room is basically my man-cave and
also my office.
In the daytime I need to have the discipline
the work in this room. Of course there are
times when I'm talking to my clients and I
get distracted by the figures.
Usually after ten when I stop work. I will
turn on all the lights and that's when
I start to admire the figures.
Sometimes when a particular
figure catches my eye, I will take it off
the shelf, try to play with it.
Displaying in this way the most tedious part,
a collector faces is to clean up.
It cost about 10 K to do all the display so
no choice if you love this hobby and you
would like to display it, the only way
you have to do is also to clean it up, to
make the figure looks the most tip-top
condition as possible.
I only clean my figures maybe about
twice a year but because every day I've
been touching them so it will get less dusty.
I'm married with two kids and have three
dogs at home. This hobby actually
has been inculcated in our daily life.
During the day when my kids are home they
will come to this room, they will look at my
display. They will try to spot if there
is anything new that I did to the display.
My kids even know the
particular characters of some of the
figures that I own.
My wife is very supportive, she actually bought me stuff
like a 1:1 War Machine bust.
She got me Mk 6 bust as well, so they
have been very supportive.
I also have this dog, her name is Vinny. She is very
close with me and she's actually the keeper
of my man cave. Whenever I'm home she'll
be inside and basically she sleeps in
this room.
I would think that as long Hot Toys
produces Iron Man, I will be preparing to
purchase it.